say you're living your best innocent
childhood life
chasing your paper boat as it floats
down the rain-smattered rivulets running
along the curb by your house
hurrying faster and faster as the stream
turns into a mini river
in most writers hands you'd have a
reasonable idea of what to expect
next but not in the hands of stephen
king now yeah sure when you say stephen
king your average joe schmoe thinks
scary and you know hey that's just fine
with uncle stevie fellow novelist john
grisham has described king
as the current holder of ablb or
america's best love bogeyman
and that paper boat she's forever lost
in the sewer held hostage by pennywise
the clown
and pennywise doesn't make balloon
animals or honk his nose well he doesn't
just do that
no he eats children just like you
few writers have had the sheer staying
power popularity and prolific output of
stephen king
from insatiably flesh-hungry clowns and
sentient cars
to telekinetic teenagers and mystical
gunslingers if there's
one author who has taken up valuable
real estate in that part of our
imaginations
it's stephen king but it's not just his
monsters that have lasting power
it's also the very human and very
psychological elements in his work that
linger
so come with me constant reader while i
lead you through the dark and twisted
world of
uncle stevie the king of horror
stephen king has been around for a while
and when i say a while i mean like
bell bottoms and watergate even before
he published his first novel carrie in
1974
he had published dozens of short stories
to date king's books have sold more than
350 million copies
he has published a staggering 61 novels
11 collections of short
stories and novellas and five works of
non-fiction to say nothing of his
screenplays
essays and yes even a musical with john
mellencamp and t-bone burnett called
ghost brothers of darkland county
but when king is actually riding which
when he's in the middle of a project is
every day
including christmas the fourth of july
and his own birthday he's writing a lot
any avid king reader knows that when
they pick up one of his books they can
generally expect
a door doorstop
our boy his longest the unabridged
version of the stand
clocks in at 1153 pages and was
originally so long
that the publisher requested he cut 400
pages to lower production
costs says king i was asked if i would
like to make cuts to the stand
or if i would prefer someone in the
editorial department to do it
i relatively agreed to do the surgery
myself i think i did a fairly good job
for a writer who has been accused
over and over again of having diarrhea
of the word processor
in other words as the verbose author
uncharacteristically put it succinctly
i have a real problem with bloat i write
like a fat lady diets
yike so just how does king maintain such
a consistent output over the course of
almost five decades
well remember that aforementioned strict
work ethic that glues king to his
keyboard
even on his own birthday according to
king i like to get 10 pages a day which
amounts to 2000 words
that's 180 thousand words over a
three-month span a good-ish length for a
book the first draft of a book even a
long one
should take no more than three months
the length of a season but king is the
first to admit that he's been slowing
down a bit
according to him i think it was quitting
smoking that slowed me down nicotine is
a great synapse enhancer
and here deer reader is where his tail
takes a darker turn
the relentless demon of addiction that
not only plagued so much of his life
but also informed a lot of his work king
has always been open about the dark
periods in his life that have influenced
his writing
both for good and ill for example cujo a
novel about a mother and her young son
stranded in a stifling car surrounded by
a rabid saint bernard
is a novel king himself likes but sadly
he was so drunk that he barely remembers
writing it
says king i was drinking a case of 16
ounce tall boys a night
i don't say that with pride or shame
only with a vague sense of sorrow and
loss
i like that book i wish i could remember
enjoying the good parts as i put them
down on the page
on the opposite end of the spectrum is
his alien invasion opus
the tommy knockers which king claims is
an awful book
when he wrote it in the spring and
summer of 1986 he was often working
until midnight with my heart running at
130 beats a minute
and cotton swabs stuck up my nose to
stem the coke induced bleeding
that the tommy knockers was the last one
i wrote before i cleaned up my act
while king did a lot of hard work in the
90s getting clean a freak car accident
in 1999
while he was taking one of his nightly
walks nearly ended his life and some
time after an addiction to painkillers
entered back into the narrative
his first book while recovering from the
injury an alien invasion called
dreamcatcher
was the freakish offspring of severe
pain and heavy doses of oxycontin the
novel delves deep into the invaders
nicknamed
[ __ ] weasel that just ate in their
host's stomachs only to violently and
gruesomely burst from their rectums
dreamcatcher is also a book that king is
not a fan of he says
i don't like dreamcatcher very much i
was pretty stoned when i wrote it
because of the oxy
and that's another book that shows the
drugs at work addiction is a pervasive
theme in many king texts
the shining about a troubled father who
gives into his demons both the
ghostly and bottled variety is a
447-page metaphor for alcoholism
and king admits that there was a part of
him that knew he was an alcoholic while
he was writing it
even though he couldn't admit it at the
time and misery wait i thought that was
about a crazy fan so obsessed with an
author that she's willing to kill him to
squeeze one final book out of him
nope misery is a book about cocaine
annie wilkes is cocaine
she was my number one fan and this is
what makes stephen king so successful
he uses surface level fears to examine
the things that truly horrify us
it's not that there are literal monsters
and demons that stalk a state a day
it's that king finds metaphorical ways
to personify them
as fellow novelist walter mosley put it
king's phenomenal popularity is due to
his almost instinctual understanding of
the fears that form the psyche of
america's working class
he knows fear and not the fear of
demonic forces alone
but also of loneliness and poverty of
hunger and the unknown we have to breach
in order to survive
trauma is always there an omnipresent
part of the human
experience the trauma of helplessness
and loss of agency
the trauma of abuse and fear of your own
loved ones and the biggest one of all
childhood trauma
he's done that one a few times i mean
the creature from it literally takes the
form of whatever will be most
traumatizing to each kid
ensuring that each and every one of them
will have a hell of a time growing up
this is all a long-winded way of saying
as mr diarrhea of the word processor put
it
you don't get scared of monsters you get
scared four people
this ability to grapple with the deeper
more profound horrors that pervade the
human condition
has allowed king to branch out into just
about every genre
making him a slippery rider to pin down
genre wise but to reductively label king
as just a horror writer
is like saying tolkien is just a guy who
writes about jewelry
for every child killing clown king has
given us he's also given us a
tender love story about loss and for
every rabid saint bernard we get an
inspirational story of redemption from a
maximum security prison
two of them literary critic michael r
collings calls this
generic indecisiveness which english
lecturer john sears observes is a
hallmark of king's works
as they demonstrate an unwillingness or
inability to be confined to singular
generic categories
they tend instead to fray at their
generic edges sprawl over boundaries
allowing different genres to seep into
each other this refusal to be confined
to one genre
is no more abundantly clear than in
king's sprawling dark tower series
eight volumes spanning 30 years of his
career and whose characters ideas and
world
make cameos and many of king's other
non-dark power works
if you've read the dark tower try
describing it just try and no
you're not allowed to cheat and give me
that matthew mcconaughey movie
it's only fitting to end our examination
of a master storyteller
with a story this one paraphrased from
king himself
way back after carrie debuted king and
his editor were waiting at a crosswalk
trying to decide which book king would
publish next
road work or salem's lot there were pros
and cons to each
but his editor's main concern was that
if they went with salem's lot
king would most assuredly be typed as a
horror writer king said
i don't care what they call me as long
as the checks don't bounce so they went
with salem's lot the modern american
vampire bestseller
and the checks certainly didn't bounce
and the result well
i was indeed typed as a horror writer a
tag i have never confirmed or denied
simply because i think it's irrelevant
to what i do it does however give
bookstores a handy place to shelve my
books
king's work is so expansive so sprawling
and so exhaustively wide and deep
that we could spend an entire youtube
channel explaining it
maybe we should but at the end of the
day we need some place to put his books
just make sure those shelves are a safe
distance from your bed
because there's nothing like sharing a
nightmare with stephen king
good night and sweet dreams constant
reader
having a rough year well you're not
alone we're all trying to make sense of
2020.
that's why we think you should check out
self-evident a new show hosted by our
friends danielle bainbridge and ali matu
because who better than a historian and
a therapist to help guide us through
this very weird year
link in our description
you